VERY MUCH IN THE MAKING AND
WILL BE, IF COMPLETED, A
VERY GOOD ONE FOR THE WORLD.
TIME AND PLACE TO BE
DETERMINED.
LET'S DISCUSS HOW THE
PRESIDENT SHOULD PROCEED
WITH LARRY FOR THE CENTER
FOR AMERICAN PROGRESS AND
FOX NEWS FOREIGN POLICY
ANALYST KIRON SKINNER.
THANK YOU BOTH FOR BEING
HERE.
WE REALLY DO APPRECIATE IT
WHAT ARE THE PERILS WHAT ARE
THE PROBLEMS AND WHAT ARE
THE CHALLENGES?
WHAT MINE FIELDS POTENTIALLY
LAY OUT THERE?
LARRY?
>> WELL, I THINK THE REAL
QUESTION IS WHAT ARE YOUR
PRECONDITIONS?
AND WHAT WILL HAPPEN WHEN
YOU MAKE A DEAL IF YOU DO.
FOR EXAMPLE, LET'S SAY KIM
AGREES TO GIVE UP ALL OF HIS
NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
THE QUESTION IS HOW ARE YOU
GOING TO VERIFY THAT?
IT TAKES A COUPLE YEARS TO
SET UP AN INSPECTION REGIME
AS WE SAW IN IRAN AND EVEN
THEN THE PRESIDENT DOESN'T
THINK IT'S THAT GOOD.
NORTH KOREA IS MUCH MORE
DIFFICULT TO INSPECT.
WHAT WILL YOU DO IF YOU
DON'T COME TO AN AGREEMENT?
THEN WHAT NEXT?
BECAUSE KIM HAS BEEN
LEGITIMIZED.
I MEAN, THIS IS A RUTHLESS
DICTATOR WHO DOES HORRIBLE
THINGS TO HIS OWN PEOPLE.
ENOUGH TO YOU HAVE MET WITH
HIM, SOMETHING HE HAS BEEN
TRYING WITH THE LAST FOUR
PRESIDENTS WHO TURNED HIM
DOWN, SO HE WALKS AWAY WITH
SOMETHING.
I THINK THOSE, YOU SHOULD
HAVE THOUGHT OF THAT.
AND EVEN TODAY THEY KEPT
SENDING DIFFERENT MESSAGES.
SOME PRECONDITIONS.
NO PRECONDITIONS.
YOU KNOW, WHAT'S YOUR PLAN?
NORMALLY, WHEN YOU HAVE
HEADS OF STATE MEET, YOU
HAVE NEGOTIATORS AHEAD OF
TIME WORK OUT THINGS.
>> YOU DO BELIEVE THAT THE
PRESIDENT IS DOING THE RIGHT
THING AND THAT HE SHOULD
ACTUALLY TAKE THIS MEETING.
>> OH, YEAH, I THINK HE
SHOULD.
I THINK HE NEEDS TO DO IT IN
THE RIGHT WAY AND LESSEN THE
RISKS.
>> Jason: KYRON, WHAT'S YOUR
TAKE ON THIS?
IS THE PRESIDENT DOING THE
RIGHT THING.
>> I DISAGREE WITH THE WAY
LARRY HAS PRESENTED IT.
I DON'T THINK THE DANGERS
AND PIT FALLS EXIST AS MANY
OF THE DETRACTORS ARE TRYING
TO SAY AT LEAST FOR THIS
REASON SINCE 1992.
WE HAVE HAD DISCUSSIONS
GOING ON WITH THE NORTH
KOREANS AT LOWER LEVELS OF
THE GOVERNMENT.
THEY ENDED UP INCON
CLIEWIVELG WAY.
BECAUSE WE ARE DEALING WITH
AUTHORITARIAN REGIME.
REALLY A TOTALITARIAN
LEADERSHIP, IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT THE TOP OF THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT BE INVOLVED IN
THE INITIAL DISCUSSIONS WITH
THE NORTH KOREAN LEADER.
SO WHAT LOOKS
UNCONVENTIONAL, I THINK
REALLY REFLECTS THE REALITY
OF THE FAILED POLICY OF MORE
THAN A COUPLE OF DECADES.
AND WE'RE GOING IN TO THIS,
MAYBE THERE ARE DIFFERENT
MESSAGES COMING OUT OF
WASHINGTON AND OUT OF NORTH
KOREA AS A RESULT OF THIS,
YOU KNOW, UNUSUAL
ANNOUNCEMENT AND UNUSUAL
APPROACH.
BUT THE FACT REMAINS THAT
THE U.S. REMAINS COMMITTED
TO DEGRADING NORTH KOREA.
IT'S GOING IN WITH A HISTORY
BEHIND ITS BACK AND HAVING
LEARNED LESSONS OF ALL THE
FAFERLS OF NEGOTIATIONS IN
THE PAST.
>> LARRY, HOW DO YOU -- WHY
DO YOU THINK WE EVEN GOT TO
THIS POSITION?
IT SEEMS LIKE THE ONE THING
THAT HAS CHANGED IS
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
HE HAS ACTUALLY TAKEN A VERY
AGGRESSIVE STANCE.
HE HAS USED UNCONVENTIONAL
COMMUNICATION, IF YOU WILL.
DON'T YOU -- DO YOU GIVE
SOME CREDENCE TO THAT OR IS
THERE ANY BELIEF THAT THAT
IS ACTUALLY WHAT DROVE THE
NORTH KOREANS TO THE TABLE?
>> I THINK THERE IS TWO
THINGS.
ONE, HE HAS REACHED A POINT
WHERE HE IS READY TO GO
NUCLEAR.
SINCE PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS
COME, IN HE HAS HAD 22
TESTS, VARIOUS THINGS.
SO HE IS WHERE HE WANTS TO
BE.
AND THE QUESTION BECOMES NOW
WHAT NEXT?
AND IF HE IS WILLING TO GIVE
THIS UP, EVEN IF YOU CAN
VERIFY THE QUESTION WHAT IS
HE GOING TO WANT IN RETURN?
IS HE GOING TO ASK US TO
TAKE OUR TROOPS OUT OF SOUTH
KOREA FOR EXAMPLE?
THOSE ARE QUESTIONS THAT WE
NEED TO THINK ABOUT BEFORE
WE GET IN THERE.
QUR'AN IS RIGHT, WE
CAR'AN IS RIGHT, WE
CAREAN IS RIGHT, WE
KIREAN IS RIGHT, WE
KIROAN IS RIGHT, WE
KIRONN IS RIGHT, WE
KIRON IIS RIGHT, WE
KIRON ISS RIGHT, WE
KIRON IS RRIGHT, WE
KIRON IS RIGGHT, WE
KIRON IS RIGHTT, WE
KIRON IS RIGHT., WE
YOU DON'T WANT LOWER LEVEL
PERSON MAKING A MISTAKE.
IF HE DOES IT IT'S VERY HARD
TO UNDO.
>> DOES IT MATTER WHERE IT
HAPPENS?
YOU WANT TO GET TO THE
SUBSTANCE OF WHAT'S
HAPPENING.
WHERE SHOULD THEY DO THIS?
>> I DON'T THINK IT REALLY
MATTERS.
IT WOULD BE, I DON'T
IT WOULD BE, A DON'T
IT WOULD BE, APPON'T
IT WOULD BE, APPRO'T
IT WOULD BE, APPROPRIATE ON
THE KOREAN PENINSULA.
SEND A MAJOR SIGNAL TO THE
ASIAN PARTNERS IF IT
HAPPENED THERE.
LET ME SPEAK TO THE POINT
ABOUT THE PRESIDENT AND
MAKING MISTAKES.
THE PRESIDENT IS NOT GOING
INTO NEGOTIATIONS WITH KIM
JONG UN.
HE IS GOING IN TO
DISCUSSIONS AND TALKS.
AND IF YOU GO BACK TO THE
REAGAN ADMINISTRATION, THERE
WAS NO POSSIBILITY OF
GETTING THE FIRST NUCLEAR
DISARMAMENT AGREEMENT OF THE
COLD WAR HAD IT NOT BEEN FOR
REAGAN AND MIKHAIL GORBACHEV
BUILDING A PERSONAL
RELATIONSHIP AND TALKING AND
REAGAN TALKING WITH OTHER
RUSSIAN LEADERS, SUCH AS --
DURING THOSE YEARS.
I THINK WE HAVE GOT TO ALSO
GIVE THE PRESIDENT A KIND OF
WIDE LATITUDE HERE BECAUSE
HE IS JUST GOING TO TALK.
AND BEGIN TO LAY THE
GROUNDWORK FOR THE
NEGOTIATIONS THAT WILL
FOLLOW.
>> YEAH, BUT REAGAN NEVER